The reading program is a community outreach program.
It enables children in our community to come in, read to the cats,...
...earn prizes and spend some extra loving on our cats here at the shelter.
It helps improve the children's reading skills as well as their self-esteem.
I'm reading Bruce and Juliet, the dragon story.
I'm reading to some of the cats.
And before the one cat went up there and was just sitting there...
...and I was reading and it was staring at me.
I like coming here because my favorite type of animal is cats,...
...big cats, small cats, medium cats.
My favorite type of cat is a tiger and I have a Siamese.
I've been getting e-mails and phone calls from parents,...
...thanking us for having this program at the shelter.
It's improved their children's skills at school.
It's boosted their self-esteem through the roof.
So it's been well received all around.